Générique
...
Musique dramatique
-Incendies dévastateurs,
séismes meurtriers,
inondations,
désastres industriels,
épidémies...
Ces catastrophes naturelles,
technologiques et sanitaires
mobilisent des spécialistes
des interventions d'urgence
et de la gestion de crise :
les sapeurs-sauveteurs
de la sécurité civile.
-Quelle est leur mission ?
Etre la force d'action rapide
de la sécurité civile.
-Un sapeur-sauveteur,
c'est un soldat et un serviteur
avec cette capacité à durer
dans le temps sur une intervention
et à vivre
dans des conditions de rusticité
parfois complexes.
-Ces 1400 militaires
mis pour emploi auprès du ministère
de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
montent en première ligne
quand les secours
sont surchargés
ou que la situation
frise le chaos.
Mobilisables en trois heures,
en France comme à l'étranger,
ils sont
en alerte permanente,
pour servir et sauver.
En 2022, les formations militaires
de la sécurité civile
ont conduit
273 missions opérationnelles,
dont 13 à l'international.
Immersion au sein
de ces unités uniques
qui n'ont qu'une vocation :
répondre à l'urgence.
...
Musique de tension
-Le feu est arrivé de l'autre côté.
Notre but est de le bloquer
au niveau de la ligne
de crête.
On va faire un établissement
pour couper le feu
pour pas qu'il descende
sur le village derrière.
-La campagne annuelle de lutte
contre les feux de forêt
n'a pas commencé
que déjà,
les secours s'organisent.
L'été 2022, qui a notamment ravagé
le sud de la France,
est encore
dans tous les esprits.
En juin,
à 30 km de Nîmes,
se joue
un exercice d'intervention
pour contrer un feu fictif niché
dans la montagne, inaccessible
aux moyens terrestres.
La solution :
des hélicoptères
de l'armée de terre
pour acheminer
hommes, matériel
et surtout eau
au plus proche de la zone de feu.
-En fait, on commence à se mettre
en place sur notre zone.
On a 2000 l sur zone.
-Les sapeurs-sauveteurs,
en coordination
avec les sapeurs-pompiers
du Gard,
vont devoir dérouler
plus de 1 km de tuyau
avant d'atteindre la ligne de crête.
Il fait plus de 30 degrés,
sans compter
le dénivelé positif
mais surtout,
chaque secouriste
doit porter
40 kilos d'équipement.
Pendant leur intervention,
deux hélicoptères
leur fourniront de l'eau.
A chaque rotation,
c'est 1000 litres d'eau
qui sont transportés
sous élingue,
sous l'oeil attentif
d'un hélicoptère Gazelle.
C'est le détachement
d'intervention héliporté
national.
*-Tu pourras prendre
un peu de vitesse
et commencer à faire
le tour de la zone.
*-Le détachement d'intervention
héliporté national
est réellement
un outil unique en France,
armé par des militaires,
donc le ministère des Armées
et mis pour emploi,
aux frais
du ministère de l'Intérieur,
pour réaliser
un appui aux sapeurs-pompiers
en renfort
sur des feux
totalement inaccessibles.
Dès que les moyens terrestres
ne pourront pas arriver
sur un secteur du feu,
le DIHN va être engagé
à cet effet
et pourra réaliser
des extinctions
sur plusieurs kilomètres.
-Grâce à la coordination
des moyens aériens et terrestres,
la ligne de crête est atteinte
en moins d'une heure
et le pare-feu,
mis en place.
-Aujourd'hui,
on a fait une manoeuvre
avec les sapeurs-pompiers
du SDIS
du Gard,
de façon à pouvoir tout simplement
mettre en commun
nos savoir-faire.
La manoeuvre
s'est bien déroulée
et c'est un exercice
de premier choix
avant la campagne estivale.
-Exercice terminé,
les sapeurs-sauveteurs déployés
rentreront à bord
de cette nacelle de récupération
pouvant transporter
10 personnes.
*-Allez, remonte de 2 mètres.
*Propos indistincts
*-C'est stable.
*-La nacelle est stable.
-Ces sapeurs-sauveteurs
feront partie intégrante
du groupement opérationnel
de lutte contre les feux de forêt,
le dispositif GOLFF.
-La sécurité civile est
un système qui mobilise
différents acteurs
autour d'une mission très simple :
porter secours et assistance
aux populations
face à des crises multiples,
nombreuses,
les risques du quotidien
ou exceptionnels.
-Les tempêtes,
les inondations, les séismes,
les feux de forêt
sont notre coeur d'intervention
au sein
des formations militaires.
-Fin juin,
des détachements
d'intervention
des formations militaires
de la sécurité civile
ont rejoint
le sud de la France
pour la campagne
de lutte
contre les feux de forêt.
Pendant trois mois,
ce détachement
prêtera main-forte
aux services départementaux
d'incendies
et de secours locaux.
-Le détachement
d'intervention retardant
Lézignan
est composé
de 57 sapeurs-sauveteurs.
Il a deux types de composantes :
une avec des camions-citernes
feux de forêt,
une unité de fabrication retardant
et un groupe appui
constitué de bulldozers.
Notre force,
c'est la polyvalence
et l'état d'esprit militaire.
On est bien
une unité militaire
en renfort
de moyens départementaux,
en renfort de nos camarades
sapeurs-pompiers.
-Bon, très bien,
bonjour à tous.
Vous êtes un dispositif précieux
dans le SDIS de l'Aude.
Dès qu'il le faut,
on appelle la zone de défense
pour autoriser
votre engagement
le plus tôt possible.
L'idée est,
sur les feux, d'avoir
les moyens les plus importants
sur les feux naissants.
Frapper vite et fort,
c'est la doctrine nationale.
Comme chaque année,
depuis près de 25 ans,
on a les pompiers de l'Aude
qui sont mobilisés et on a
une unité de sécurité civile
qui est prépositionnée
au profit
de la zone de défense.
Ils vont apporter leur savoir-faire,
ce sont des gens aguerris
bien préparés,
avec des moyens spécialisés
grâce à cette unité retardant.
-Nous, notre spécificité,
c'est la pose du retardant,
ce produit un peu rougeâtre.
C'est un produit qu'on pose
de façon préventive
face à des feux de forêt
et ça nous permet de créer
des barrières.
Quand le feu arrive dessus,
ça permet de réduire
sa propagation,
voire de l'atténuer
totalement.
Musique de tension
-Prépositionné dans l'Aude
pour intervenir vite,
il n'est pas question pour autant
de rester inactif et d'attendre.
-Pour l'ensemble des 33,
ici code ELI 33.
On prend
un départ de feu.
Donc, direction plein nord.
*-33 de 333, feu dévié
et il part
sur 332.
*Propos indistincts
*...
-Là, on s'entraîne
en conditions réelles.
On utilise des scénarios
que nous ou d'autres ont déjà vécus
pour les reproduire
et s'entraîner dessus.
Dans certains départements,
comme la zone sud,
c'est une zone qui est à risque
et qui est stratégique
par l'autoroute
et les différents accès
qui nous permettent de partir vite,
à l'est comme à l'ouest
de la zone sud.
-En plus de ces entraînements,
le détachement
d'intervention retardant
quadrille
au quotidien sa zone d'action
en coordination
avec les moyens de secours
et de sécurité locaux.
Le but : toujours être
en mouvement
pour intervenir au plus vite,
mais aussi être visible et dissuader
les tentatives de mise à feu.
-Si on met de côté l'année 2022
qui a été une année
à tout point de vue exceptionnelle,
2023 a été une saison de feux
raisonnablement active.
Il y a eu 30 % de départs de feu
en plus qu'en 2021,
mais comme nous avions
des moyens mis au service
d'une stratégie éprouvée,
nous avons pu fort heureusement
avoir un bilan tout à fait maîtrisé.
-Un été 2023
qui reste sans commune mesure
avec celui
que les sapeurs-sauveteurs
ont connu l'an dernier,
en Gironde notamment.
...
A la mi-juillet,
deux feux simultanés
plongeaient
le massif des Landes de Gascogne
dans les flammes.
Au total, c'est 25 000 hectares
qui sont réduits en cendres.
L'ampleur
et la durée de ces feux
ont marqué les esprits.
-2022 était exceptionnelle,
j'ai été engagé avec mon détachement
plus de 14 fois,
dans plusieurs départements,
notamment en Gironde, à Landiras.
-Ca a duré tout l'été,
tout l'été constamment,
on s'arrêtait jamais.
On venait à partir
sur plusieurs feux.
On est parfois restés
jusqu'à 11 jours dessus.
-Un mégafeu se voit
à des kilomètres.
C'est très impressionnant.
Par exemple, on arrivait de nuit,
un brouillard épais...
on voyait pas à plus de 5 mètres
au niveau des véhicules,
on voyait vraiment à peine
les gyrophares.
Dans la forêt des Landes,
les pins faisaient 20 ou 25 mètres
et quand ça prenait en cime,
vous rajoutez
5-6 mètres de flamme en plus.
On se déplaçait en regardant
la ligne au sol.
C'était compliqué,
ça prend la gorge,
ça pique les yeux,
donc on respire toujours des fumées.
-C'est long, c'est éprouvant.
Maintenant, on a un système
qui nous permet de nous relever
entre nous, tenir dans la durée.
-Bien évidemment, quand on est face
à des sinistres exceptionnels,
il peut y avoir des moments
de doute. Maintenant,
on est entraînés,
on est formés,
et c'est là
où toute notre formation,
notre état militaire,
avec la cohésion,
la chaîne de commandement,
qui fait notre force,
nous permet de mener
la mission à bien.
-En 2022, à l'occasion
de la saison de feux très difficile
que nous avons connue en France,
heureusement que nous avions
les FORMISC pour aider
les sapeurs-pompiers civils
à lutter contre les feux
dans le sud-est et le sud-ouest.
Donc, ça, c'est vraiment
les qualités militaires
que les FORMISC portent très haut,
mais qui sont mises
au service d'une mission civile.
-Pour l'année 2022,
c'est plus de 200-220 interventions
tant sur le sol national
qu'à l'étranger.
-Si, aujourd'hui,
les sapeurs-sauveteurs
sont le bras armé de l'Etat
en matière de sécurité civile,
ces formations sont récentes.
Aux origines des sapeurs-sauveteurs,
un drame qui remonte
à 1959, la rupture
du barrage de Malpasset.
-C'est en pleine nuit
que se produisit la tragédie.
Les 50 millions
de mètres cubes d'eau
retenus dans le lac long de 10 km
ont déferlé comme un mur
de 5 mètres de haut
à travers la vallée,
à la vitesse de 70 km/h.
En sept minutes,
tout était consommé.
-Plus de 50 millions de mètres cubes
d'eau ravagent Fréjus
et son agglomération, causant
la mort de plus de 400 personnes.
Face à l'ampleur des dégâts,
des militaires
du 7e régiment du génie d'Avignon
sont appelés en renfort
pour soutenir les secours civils,
dépassés par l'ampleur
de la catastrophe.
Cette combinaison de secours
donnera l'idée
au général de Gaulle
de créer
une force militaire experte
des catastrophes naturelles,
les FORMISC.
Créées officiellement en 1974,
elles sont composées
aujourd'hui
d'un état-major, basé à Paris,
et de trois unités d'intervention
de la sécurité civile,
réparties sur le territoire
entre le Var,
l'Eure-et-Loir et la Corse.
Mais pour devenir un expert
de la gestion des crises,
il faut sans cesse se former
et entretenir ses savoir-faire.
La formation interne
des sauveteurs
a une place centrale.
En 2022, 360 stages
ont été dispensés
à plus de 4500 stagiaires,
comme Mélanie,
cette jeune sergent de 25 ans.
Cheffe de groupe
en section d'intervention,
elle participe à un stage
de sauvetage-déblaiement,
un apprentissage nécessaire
pour effectuer de la recherche
sous décombres.
-Pourquoi vous vous équipez,
sergent ?
-Parce que je vais partir
en manoeuvre.
Là, le départ,
on l'a prévu à 20h.
Je m'équipe pour partir
un peu en avance
et avoir le briefing.
-Un séisme de 6,2
a eu lieu le 21 mai
à 3h58 du matin.
Epicentre à l'ouest
de la ville de Velleron,
pour 7 kilomètres.
Nous dénombrons à 20h
535 disparus,
390 morts
et 1143 blessés.
-Donc là, ils vont partir
pour combien de temps ?
-Ils partent
pour une séquence de 6 heures.
Ils partiront
se reposer 6 heures.
Une autre équipe les relèvera.
Le but est de travailler
dans la durée sur ce rythme.
-En sauvetage-déblaiement,
plus le temps passe,
plus le bilan peut s'alourdir.
A la tête d'un groupe
de sept sauveteurs,
Mélanie a 6 heures
pour secourir
le plus de victimes possible,
piégées dans cet ancien complexe
hôtelier désaffecté.
-Sur ton secteur,
tu as apparemment
une poche de survie en R-1.
-D'accord.
-C'est au niveau
d'une boîte de nuit.
Il y a pas mal de voix,
pas mal de gens qui appellent
à ce niveau-là.
On va faire
la reconnaissance là-bas.
Les deux entrées de la boîte
sont effondrées
et c'est instable.
-D'accord.
-J'ai vu une ouverture,
que tu vas pouvoir essayer
d'exploiter
pour atteindre la boîte.
Il y a eu un effondrement.
Un bloc de béton est tombé dessus.
Là, si t'arrives à dégager,
tu peux te faire un accès.
Le problème, c'est
qu'il y a pas d'engin de TP.
Il va falloir que tu perces.
Ca va être un peu long.
Commence
avant que la nuit tombe.
C'est une course
contre la montre.
Il va falloir aller
les chercher à fond.
-Le groupe d'intervention s'engage.
Les sapeurs-sauveteurs
vont perforer cette plaque de béton
de 20 cm d'épaisseur.
Vrombissement de perceuse
-On est là !
On est là !
-Arrêtez, monsieur.
Quatre personnes.
-On est là ! Ca répond pas !
...
-Là, on est en train de percer
pour accéder à R-1, mais je me dis
que j'ai le reste de l'équipe
en stand-by.
-Il faut pas
que tu restes trop
le nez dedans.
Tu prends du recul,
t'observes la situation.
T'as deux mecs
qui travaillent
et d'autres, non.
Il faut que tu les occupes.
-Je peux commencer l'appel.
-Mélanie revoit sa stratégie.
Des victimes pourraient se trouver
dans les étages du bâtiment.
-C'est les secours !
Vous m'entendez ?
Vrombissement d'outils de forage
...
-On a une victime.
Je te laisse prendre contact
avec elle.
OK.
-Monsieur !
Serrez-moi les mains.
Vous m'entendez ?
-Dans ce laps de temps,
les sapeurs-sauveteurs
sont venus à bout
de la plaque de béton.
-Levez.
Allez, avancez doucement,
comme tout à l'heure.
...
-On vient d'évacuer
plusieurs victimes.
On en a évacué trois
qui étaient au R-1.
On a fait un percement assez long.
On a réussi à les atteindre.
Là, on va aller
sur une manip
au niveau du R+4.
On est en train de mettre
un dispositif de poulie pour évacuer
une personne à plat,
qui a un trauma au rachis.
Levez, levez, levez.
-Lève.
Lève, lève, lève, lève.
C'est bon.
-OK.
*Propos indistincts
*-Evacuez avant 2h55.
-Après 6 heures d'efforts,
Mélanie a extrait, avec son groupe,
10 victimes.
Un bilan positif,
pour son instructeur.
-Encore, encore !
-Autant de victimes sorties
en si peu de temps,
c'est relativement bien.
Les points à améliorer
qu'elle avait par rapport à hier
ont été améliorés aujourd'hui.
C'est encourageant
pour la suite.
J'ai pu participer au séisme
qu'il y a eu en Haïti en 2010.
On y faisait plus
de la recherche en décombres.
Le raisonnement reste le même :
travailler au plus vite
pour récupérer
un maximum de victimes.
Musique grave
-Le 12 janvier 2010,
un tremblement de terre
de magnitude 7 frappe Haïti,
ce petit pays des Caraïbes.
L'épicentre du séisme se situe
à 25 kilomètres
de sa capitale, Port-au-Prince.
On dénombre plus
de 280 000 morts,
300 000 blessés
et 1,3 million de sans-abri.
Face à l'urgence,
les sapeurs-sauveteurs français
sont déployés
en première ligne.
La recherche sous décombres
n'attend pas.
-On est arrivés les premiers.
Il y avait tout à faire.
On a eu la chance de trouver
des vivants.
C'était le chaos.
Haïti, pour reprendre un peu
les chiffres,
c'était presque 250 000 morts,
300 000 blessés.
C'était le chaos.
Tout était à terre,
tout était désorganisé.
Voilà,
je vous laisse imaginer
un petit peu le décor.
Ouais, c'était pas évident,
et nous, les sapeurs-sauveteurs,
on a apporté notre pierre,
on a sorti des vivants.
Sur la mission,
les sapeurs-sauveteurs sortent
14 victimes du séisme.
La chance est là,
mais effectivement,
on se prépare toute l'année
pour des missions comme ça.
Notre job,
c'est d'être prêts à intervenir
pour des catastrophes
de ce type.
En plus, en ayant la chance
de pouvoir sauver des vies,
c'était un épanouissement
professionnel incroyable.
On donne tout pour cette mission.
C'est très dur.
On s'inscrit dans ça :
servir pour sauver.
-Ce que je constate,
c'est que depuis quelques années,
on est quand même confrontés
à une récurrence
de catastrophes
plutôt majeures, importantes.
On l'a vu
sur des feux de forêt catastrophes
l'année dernière.
On l'a vu sur l'apparition
de cyclones, de tempêtes
d'une violence extrême.
On le voit par la récurrence
de séismes à nos portes.
Nous nous préparons
le plus possible,
le plus sérieusement possible,
de façon professionnelle,
à y faire face
pour pouvoir porter une assistance
à toutes les populations
qui en auraient le besoin.
-Ca, c'est la plus noble
des missions qui puisse exister,
cette capacité à porter
le meilleur de ces deux cultures,
le meilleur
de la culture militaire
et le meilleur
des acteurs du secours.
Cette capacité à mélanger,
à allier ces deux cultures,
c'est ce qui fait vraiment,
je crois,
le prix et la valeur
des FORMISC.
-Tremblements de terre,
feux de forêt, inondations,
pleinement engagés
sur tous ces fronts
au cours de leurs 50 années
d'existence, les sapeurs-sauveteurs
ont aussi dû faire face
à de nouvelles menaces,
notamment industrielles
et sanitaires.
-Situation :
vous venez d'être déclenchés
pour un accident,
un déversement
de liquide toxique
au sein d'une usine.
Un employé aurait eu un accident
lors du transport d'une cuve
de 1 mètre cube de produit.
La cuve serait tombée.
-Ces sapeurs-sauveteurs
participent
à un stage de deux semaines.
L'objectif :
devenir chef d'équipe d'intervention
en milieu chimique.
-Là, j'envoie un premier binôme
de reconnaissance
en tenue intégrale.
-C'est les tenues jaunes ?
-C'est ça.
C'est des tenues
qui sont étanches au gaz.
Leur but, c'est d'aller faire
une reconnaissance de la zone,
d'identifier,
de localiser si possible
la fuite.
-Le premier binôme s'engage
pour expertiser la situation.
Ce sont les yeux du lieutenant
sur la zone à risque.
*-Est-ce que vous avez une idée
du volume qui s'est déversé ?
-Nous avons un...
Propos indistincts
Il est à moitié rempli
et il se déverse dans les égouts.
-Le caporal Tanguy reste en retrait.
Il fait partie
de l'équipe d'intervention
en formation.
-On va obturer une bouche d'égout
d'environ 30 centimètres.
On va mettre
un boudin gonflable
et on va y aller en binôme.
-Le risque d'explosion
est ici secondaire.
On reste sur un risque
toxique en principal.
Là, votre mission
est de limiter au maximum
le gaz déjà écoulé dans les égouts.
Musique énigmatique
-En matière de risques chimiques,
chaque geste compte.
Pas question d'être contaminé
ou d'être vecteur
de contamination.
-Celui en tenue orange,
c'est le sas man.
Le sas,
c'est ce que vous voyez ici.
C'est le sas d'entrée
et de sortie de la zone dangereuse.
La zone dangereuse se situe
à partir du sas.
Au-delà, on doit être contrôlé
par le sas man.
Il va vérifier
que les équipements de protection
sont bien mis,
pour qu'on n'ait pas de fuite,
que ce soit bien hermétique
et que les binômes
soient en sécurité.
-Avec un équipement
de près de 25 kg,
sans compter la chaleur
et le manque de visibilité
de ces tenues étanches,
la manoeuvre est éprouvante.
Souffle d'appareils respiratoires
...
-Chef d'équipe,
ici binôme à terre.
Donc, après la pose
du couvre-égout,
on est à 0 ppm.
Parlez.
*-Bien reçu.
Donc, pour vous, retour au sas.
-Il fait assez chaud
dans la tenue, ça se voit.
La manoeuvre en elle-même
n'est pas dure.
Le boudin, c'est pas très compliqué,
mais c'est le port
des équipements de protection.
On voit vraiment rien.
On s'entend pas.
On a un système de transmission
pour communiquer,
mais c'est difficile.
-Vous allez être amenés,
quand vous serez certifiés,
à opérer où,
dans quel contexte ?
-Ben, pour nous,
ça peut être des missions
en France métropolitaine
ou à l'étranger,
diverses missions.
-Vous avez des exemples en tête ?
-On est partis au Liban en 2020
sur l'explosion à Beyrouth.
Il y a eu une intervention
à risques chimiques
au niveau du port
sur les containers.
Musique sombre
-Le 4 août 2020,
deux explosions ravagent
le port de Beyrouth :
235 personnes sont tuées
et 6500 sont blessées.
En moins de 24 heures,
les sapeurs-sauveteurs français
interviennent
sur une mission
de sauvetage-déblaiement,
mais également
dans le cadre
d'un risque chimique,
car la deuxième explosion
a fait sauter un hangar contenant
entre 400 et 600 t
de nitrate d'ammonium,
utilisé généralement
comme engrais,
mais aussi
comme matière explosive.
-On est arrivés
en pleine nuit.
On a dû monter le camp.
Une 1re équipe est intervenue
au niveau des silos
sur le port
pour faire
des reconnaissances de surface,
pour voir s'il y avait
des victimes.
-Là, oui, c'était vraiment
un très, très gros chaos.
Il y avait beaucoup d'agitation,
de tension dans l'air.
-Une deuxième équipe
est intervenue au niveau
des containers de produits chimiques
pour mettre en sécurité
tous les containers
et pour éviter les fuites.
-Il y avait des cuves
de produits chimiques.
On fait en sorte que les produits
ne se mélangent pas entre eux,
sous peine
de réactions violentes.
Là, l'objectif,
c'était de retirer
les cuves
des containers endommagés,
les cuves notamment
qui pouvaient fuir un peu.
Les retirer, les rincer,
les décontaminer
et les remettre ensuite
dans des containers intacts,
de manière à éviter
tout ce risque lié
au mélange des produits.
C'était une mission
assez compliquée
de par ce qu'on pouvait
voir ou faire,
mais on sentait
qu'on était utiles.
On en ressort toujours plus grands
humainement, techniquement.
On est tout le temps
dans la préparation
de l'opérationnel,
dans l'objectif d'y aller.
-J'ai commandé
des soldats combattants
de l'armée de terre
et je commande aujourd'hui
des sapeurs-sauveteurs.
Ce qui unit les deux,
ce qui est vraiment l'ancrage,
l'ADN qui unit les deux,
c'est le service,
c'est le service à autrui,
c'est le serviteur.
-C'est à ça que servent les FORMISC.
C'est le couteau suisse
de la sécurité civile
et l'excellence
de la sécurité civile :
porter secours aux populations
en France et à l'étranger.
-Dans un monde
de plus en plus en proie
à ces nouvelles menaces
et face à une nature déréglée,
les sapeurs-sauveteurs
doivent, peut-être plus
qu'avant, être prêts
à s'engager
dans ces catastrophes
qui ne préviennent pas,
comme en Libye récemment.
Leur militarité, alliant rusticité
et sens de la planification,
et leur connaissance
du milieu du secours civil en font
un maillon-clé
du secours français.
Preuve de leur nécessité :
une nouvelle unité
d'instruction et d'intervention
de la sécurité civile
devrait voir le jour en 2024,
avec un but :
répondre à l'urgence,
pour servir, pour sauver.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...